Ladies and gentlemen, I'm excited for this one today.
We're talking about a conversation that was leaked to me, uh,
via an anonymous tip.
And it's a conversation between two scammers and it allows us to rare look into
how they think, how you can spot them. And more importantly,
the kind of trash that's being allowed,
promulgated push on Instagram all the time.
People trying to get you to hand over your money in a new way.
You guys all know about the Nigerian Prince,
but you don't know about a lot of these investment scams.
Now this is going to be a two part series because,
because today we're talking about the inside. Look at that, their DMS,
their conversation, when no one's watching.
The second is a confrontation between myself and the scammer,
where I try to get to the heart of what this person is doing,
how they feel about the scam and ultimately a scammer's perspective
on the victims of a scam. It's fascinating.
I think you will find it very interesting if you like psychology,
if you like any kind of like true crime stuff, this is an insane inside.
Look at this. Um, and you rarely get that. So starting off,
let's talk about who's involved. There are two people, David Ferris, FX,
which is actually a cover. That's not his real name.
This is a fake account that is made to lure investors in to invest with this
person between this guy and another guy named stocks college.
Here it is Ray here. It's number one, stock market training program,
500 plus satisfied students, top rated funds. Okay.
Trying to get this social proof going on, right?
They're constantly posting about trade, stuff like that.
You see accounts like this all the time. Now let me say right off the bat.
One of these accounts has since been leading. That would be David Farris, FX,
which is why I wanted to compare it to a similar, um,
probably almost identical account called invest with Hilda
FX, very similar Forex expert binary, trader entrepreneur,
all this kind of stuff. Uh, DME let's earn huge profits, dah, dah, dah.
So this is basically what David Farris was doing is posting daily about Forex
all these trades, all this money, but that's who we're dealing with.
So let's set the tone. It starts off. I hope our conversation don't get leaked.
We should chat somewhere. Private. Do you have WhatsApp?
I'm going to blur out that number for privacy reasons. And this guy goes,
what happened to your personal page? I can't find it blocked you.
Why would you do that, bro? You keep changing IgE accounts.
You making it hard to do business with you. Safety bro.
My main page never changes.
So this David Ferris FX cameras basically saying I have two accounts,
one for the scam. One that's completely unassociated and stocks.
College is upset because he can't get ahold of him. But David Farris,
his reasoning is pretty clear.
Imagine police stops me and go through my Instagram I'm doc's college
response Lowell. They can't go through your Instagram. David fares, what?
Google SARS, Nigeria. They kill scammers, bro. Now,
for those of you wondering SARS is the special anti robbery squad,
which is a Nigerian based police force,
which has some extremely controversial methods of, uh,
of enforcement. As you can see here, they've been linked to acts of extortion,
torture, framing, and blackmail,
and basically a lot of people in Nigeria want them shut down.
This guy's afraid of SARS. The conversation goes on, okay man. Anyways,
they can go through your WhatsApp too. Then David Farris response,
I've got two phones. One of them is scammed free,
which is extremely interesting. And this guy feels pretty sophisticated, uh,
compared to probably a lot of scammers who don't go through all these hoops to
try to stay, you know, clean as far as their public image is concerned.
But then this guy goes, I dunno, bro, you're doing too much and I'm confused.
I need you for the scam. This is stock's college, Instagram page.
That is still up. Still trying to, I guess, get people to invest. I don't know.
Do you want to make money or not? He says, yeah, I want to make money.
But without using my official page, dude, I don't understand.
I'm using Robert DiMillo's picture on a new page. Nice man.
I need to make multiple IgE accounts and post on all of them grow all of them.
Yeah, you can do that.
So they're talking about diversifying for when they have to burn one of these
accounts. You want multiple. So moving on, they go. Yeah. Great job, man.
When someone messaged you, Bitcoin, what do you do? David Farris response.
I give them a good format. Talk to them like a company or an organization,
lead them on and give them everything legit.
Because I know the one to verify all I'm saying it will be them that will ask to
send their money. How's everything going? Great over here,
your in's chilling man.
Trying to collect as many investors as I can't any word from the Nevine guy.
I guess that's one of their leads. He then sends them some car. And then, uh,
we have our scammer going last night.
I was so visualizing myself in ask class bins.
Now let's stop for a second and say, this is what all scammers do.
All of them buy very much into this manifestation idea.
They think that if they think it, they will do it.
They get it all from the secret. They all believe in it like totally.
So you'll see a lot of that on this channel. David Farris says,
delete your comment, bro. I guess he's referring to some kind of post,
maybe on his private Instagram. I deleted it.
Why you want me to leave the comment law? I just feel in case your followers,
see it, they shouldn't know your movement. So again,
we find David Farris is constantly trying to elude detection.
He doesn't want anyone to see who he is later in the conversation.
We see more of this sort of paranoid behavior. Cool man, bro,
did you block the persuade guide? LOL? Yeah, of course I blocked.
Apparently this is probably someone who invested with them, asking for returns.
Uh, and they just block them. That's how this stuff works.
You invest and they keep you on the hook until you ask for your money back.
They promise you these super high returns. Uh, and when you do ask for it back,
they block you LOL for real ha the worst is still to come.
Who the is that? Lose it though. bro. Your Savage. No dude.
You're a scammer.
And now all of your dirty laundry is being exposed. How about that
jokes on you guys. Now stocks college says I'm going to block him too. Yup.
Block is tease the past. So this guy goes,
stocks college says I'm going to grow five new pages and buy established pages
and cash out, bro. Each account we can make easy.
80 K they're talking about scamming, raise 30 to 40 commission,
30 to 40 and extra like you did with persuade here and there.
And that's it burn the account. So this is the mechanism behind this stuff.
And I hope you guys are thinking, wow,
I'm never going to invest in an Instagram investor ever.
And you shouldn't because the chances are they're scamming.
Just like these people are, look at what this guy's talking about.
We can do three to four a year. May be or more not sure.
Let's see how it goes. Different pages, just like stock college,
just different name and brand. I will post daily content on those.
Like I do here, grow organic following and people then.
Cash out when I do a fundraise. So again, they post.
A ton of content and they say, guys, I'm starting.
A fund. I'm going to make all this money. You're going to make 200%.
You're going to make 500% and they steal it.
And here's what we're going to see a post from stocks,
college of this scam and action. So they put up these stories.
This is a stock's college, almost full.
Thank you to everyone who invested. And it says I'm raising 30 K to trade.
And once I reach it, it's kept. Don't ask me after please,
50 50 split on these daily profits you see on my page.
So this is what he's talking about right here. $13,000, a thousand dollars.
He's talking about all these, uh, pages,
supposedly where he's making all this money.
He's saying you could split the profits. Of course, this is all a lie.
He's gonna burn the account eventually. But this is how he raises the money.
And he's talking here to this guy, Mr. Persuade,
who they were talking about earlier about blocking and here it says, bro,
if Robert gives me my profits, I'm in, in other words,
this guy's already invested and he wants to invest again,
but he hasn't received his profits back. So he's saying, Hey, pay me first.
And then I'll join your new fund that you're fundraising. Right?
And what do they do? They block the guy. As you can see, laugh, laugh, laugh,
laugh, laugh. Look at these scumbags. Did,
can you imagine doing this to somebody's dish looks so legit.
He still can't find the scam in it. They're talking about Mr. Persuade trust,
bro. We are crazy. And this is really insidious. Okay.
This is where these guys do understand psychology really well. He says,
let it seem like he's the only one who hasn't received his profits.
The reason why this business will hold well is the fact that each person will
think that they are the only one that have problems.
Especially when they see you posting profits and payouts to different clients.
These is sick guys.
This is how the scam works is gaslighting.
It's fakery. It's lying. This is what they do.
They're experts at it. And again, where does this thrive on Instagram,
where you don't have to be to post all these profits to say you're such a
millionaire trader. If they're posting.
Screenshots of the trader. I mean, I don't know if I showed you guys this,
but stocks, college has an image of their trader. That's not okay.
Actually, the guy look at this,
they say senior trader located in Toronto, Canada. No,
he's not this guy. Isn't real.
This guy is a fake profile to lure you in. Again,
it's all manipulated. It's all a fraud.
And here's where the scam continues. Look at this.
Every time a person is ready to pay out, I'll send them to you. So.
Like I said, David Farris is sort of like.
Uh, the end man, stocks college is the middleman. He says,
make sure to get a testimonial and everything before you block them,
I can use that as content. So what they say is, before we pay you out,
we need a testimony. People naively do it,
thinking that they're going to about to get paid out like 500%.
They post it as if they paid it out and then block that person.
So they can't post anymore. This does two things like.
They're saying, first of all, it shows everybody else in the group. They think,
Oh yeah, people are getting paid out. No, they're not number two.
It gaslights everybody thinking that they're the only one who didn't get paid
out. Okay.
So we're going to fast forward a little bit because some of these deems are
uninteresting, bro, bro, bro, bro, that kind of stuff.
Then they start talking about burning the account.
Remember they're going to build a bunch of accounts like stocks, college,
and then burn them. When they go,
when basically they get caught out caught or you know too many investors get
burned. So David Farris is talking to him. If you're going to burn it,
it won't be now at all. Okay. I will see how it goes.
I'm going to burden in three or four months. When everyone asks for payout,
I'm going to do another fundraise in between this one.
While I show people the investors accounts, profit, again,
they haven't actually gotten the money,
but it's like allegedly what's in their account. It's a big Ponzi scheme.
Then this David Farris, hatches an idea,
pay one or two of them to K and collect videos and screenshot and post it up.
So then this guy's kind of getting, he goes, Oh,
so whoever didn't get in will get in. Yes,
they will invest again and bring more friends. Oh yeah.
So it's almost like an undetectable Ponzi scheme plan your date and then pay
investors who invested little, it's a small price to pay for the big gains.
Since the other investors will be willing to pay the commission. So again,
this is a kind of diabolical.
What they're saying is anybody who invested a little, like a hundred dollars,
maybe they're promising like 2000% returns, something crazy like that.
You actually pay them out. The two K that they're owed,
collect videos and then attract new investors. This is diabolical.
And why this is important to note is that you might,
may find an Instagram account.
That's supposedly paying out investors that supposedly as real testimonials,
right? You don't know that they're not doing this behind the scenes, right?
Secretly only paying out a few burning everybody else to
try to keep the Ponzi scheme going. A lot of people do that,
especially scammers on Instagram. And again,
look at how gleeful these people are. There's no morality here at all.
There's no thought of we're ripping people off. We're ruining people's lives.
Look at this. They're just so happy about it.
We are controlling the narrative by having multiple outs. Nice.
You're smart as hell. Perfect man. One guy gave me a hundred dollars.
I'll give him $300 and they're laughing again, guys,
this is a sickness affecting people who, number one,
they might not have other prospects in life.
Maybe that's why they feel the need to skip.
But I think the other part of it is they watch how little of this stuff is
prosecuted. How much does Instagram crack down on these accounts? Almost none.
Uh,
how much does Instagram take accountability for these actions or report them to
law enforcement? Almost none. So when this happens, they're not scared.
Look at this. They're just gleeful. Okay. Thanks bro. You're the guy helping me.
You're my only partner. So good job.
We have a huge future and that's basically it actually that's about where the
conversation ends. So I hope you learned something.
Let me know what you think in the comments below about content like this.
I really enjoyed getting into the minds of these people and tomorrow we will not
only be getting into the minds of this person. We are actually contacting him.
I confronted David Ferris, eFax. He deleted his account,
but I contacted his WhatsApp number and I just wanted to talk.
Thanks for watching. And as always.
Don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.
[inaudible].